what happens when our training data is
too big to fit on our machine or
training the model starts to take hours
we go to the cloud of course when you
have a lot of data such that you can't
reasonably run the training on your
local machine or the size of that data
is larger than your hard drive it's time
to look at other options one solid
option is to shift the machine learning
training to another computer with access
to more storage thus freeing up your
hard drive space and allowing you to
work on other things while that training
is taking place let's break down exactly
what parts need to be moved into the
cloud it's useful to think about our
training as needing two primary
resources compute and storage what's
interesting here is that we don't have
to tie them together quite as tightly as
you might have first expect we can
decouple them which yields specialized
systems for both and this can lead to
efficiencies of scale when you're
dealing with big data now compute load
is moved around easily enough but the
moving of large data sets that can be a
bit more involved however if your data
set is truly large the results are
worthwhile as it allows the data to be
accessed by many machines in parallel
that are working on your machine
learning training job Google cloud
platform has a couple of easy ways to
tie together these abstractions first
we'll want to make sure that our data is
on Google Cloud storage or GCS we can do
this using a variety of tools for the
smaller to medium data sets just use
gsutil it's a command-line tool that was
specifically made for interacting with
Google Cloud storage and it supports a -
M option that allows for sending
multiple streams in parallel thus
speeding up your transfer job but if
your data is too big to send over the
network you can use the Google transfer
appliance which is literally a machine
now will be shipped to your data center
to securely capture and transfer a whole
petabyte of data with a typical network
bandwidth of say a hundred megabits per
second it would take three years to
upload a petabyte of data over the
network even if you had a gigabit
connection it would still take four
months now who wants to wait that long
the transparent appliance on the other
hand can capture a petabyte of data in
just 25 hours that's crazy fast
now that our data is in a cloud we're
ready to run machine learning training
at scale but that's a whole topic of its
own which we will cover in our next
episode training machine learning models
on large data sets can be challenging to
accomplish with limited compute and
storage resources but it doesn't have to
be that way by moving to the cloud via
either GS util or the transfer appliance
you can train on large data sets without
any hiccups I'm you think whoa and
thanks for watching this episode of
cloud AI adventures on our next episode
we'll be exploring the other side of
running machine learning in the cloud
the compute side will even be exploring
the options when it comes to GPUs but
for now remember when you need to do
machine learning on big data sets put
your data in the cloud thanks for
watching this episode and if you're
joining this series please let me know
by liking the video and if you want more
machine learning action be sure to
subscribe to the channel to catch future
episodes as they come out thanks for
watching that episode cloud AI
adventures the whole series here and if
you have any thoughts and comments feel
free to leave them down below
[Music]